here we go against kill yawn I've got
fifty percent again super funny so I
displaying the c3 so you know what is he
doing I don't really know I think he
does know this kind of stuff okay um
what am I playing him I have more than
one line actually that I've played here
over the years let's go for one for one
of them yeah that's an old idea
I marked red ski funny enough I think
even see voice play oh but I think
taking is ok I have played them i played
this kind of thing myself with what when
I like 20 years ago when I was still
playing the Kings Indian attack on a
regular basis I never thought that it's
it's particularly great have to admit
but it's some children unit exam is a
good practical choice it's relatively
easy to play and um and it's it's not
that bad in terms of quality for for
investor time let's say yeah that's not
the most exciting position ever but I
think this might be interesting for an
ID for night see form my g4 yeah I think
c4 looks good it should at least retain
him a little bit this is easy easy move
now a night on c4 is an irritating piece
age three mmm no stairs that pressure on
the porn i cannot easily move my queen
which is like to play something like
that say queen bee six something like
that and i cannot really develop my
bishop to a to a good square
hmm job it's not easy okay that bishop I
can maybe keep on c8 if I get Luke a six
to get my look into the game that was
the idea here so what now we're okay six
that looks really like it just like an
unnatural move okay let's go back well
that I did not expect at all and just an
interesting move though he probably
wants to go Bishop f4
anyway have to play default it's kind of
useless to think think long here if
Bishop f4 is good then so be it but i
think i think i should be able to take
on c3 that should be enough takes on see
397 i think that should be a enough play
then if he has to play something meek
like taking on d4 then I'm just fine
probably am even more than fine i just
took took too long as I tend to do ok
well thats that should be good for me
with Queen cakes and and Bishop Jake's
actually now that that's an interesting
move if you mostly look like if I have
Bishop f2 possibly now here I don't have
a sugar to either was a good move I was
mostly thinking of from thinking of him
would be one who jism which is stupid
anyway ok so now that was bad really I
should have played should have let cream
shakes it was much easier that rook be
one Bishop f2 was a bit too tempting ok
now i roped his six yeah this is a way
to lose that game i was just better here
buddy other is stupid I was a stupid
move ok black resigns
yeah after after Queen D for black it's
just just just better for for no reason
let's say yeah because I'm just having
the more active position here this is
quite inconvenient I mean he should draw
of course but it was a very stupid I was
just too too fascinated by Jack
possibility yeah King takes Queen B 6
check and this is not going to be I'm
sure going to end well yeah I actually
saw that stuff but it doesn't matter of
course you get to is much stronger and
here yeah again that's nothing going on
i can do play everything ever the equal
position but this is just stupid stuff
blundering blundering like that is very
very stupid yeah i just winced that
piece there for nothing um okay we can
look back a little bit yeah d4 that's
interesting it doesn't lead to anything
but this is an interesting continuation
black also has Bishop g4 yeah but back
when i played that with what i always
felt that you also have no have nothing
special whatsoever in this position also
night at five is ok but i think the way
I played is some is also fine so it's
it's about equal and QA h three yeah i
think it's about equal because those
pawns are also not exactly great if he
wants to do something yes to clearly
play Bishop e3 95 is just a mistake here
it's some it's again i think it's about
equal i have this this this some isss
counterplay targets and she after that
um black is better is this a little bit
now if i take with the Queen then he has
to be precise and this is just a
basically the quickest possible way to
the to blunder that too
under that game thanks for watching